alors attention jennifer tu es fait
partie du jury de the voice tous les
samedis et bien jennifer ce soir il ya
trois personnes qui vont venir chanter
et tu nous diras si tu te retourne pas
ne te sens pas obligé de te retourner
vraiment fait comme si tu étais dans the
voice d'accord et ne te fie qu'à la voir
il n'y a qu'à la voie d'accord alors
attention on va appeler une première
personne qui va chanter qui va nous
chanter une chanson en italien via
économie de paolo conte et attendez
attendez en attendant ton micro meilleur
il ya des gens qui travaillent se tenir
ou pas du tout merci je fais tout allez
c'est parti
mais on y va pour mon frère
d'accompagnantes allemande
en neuf ans
[Musique]
choquée qu'elle ait eu la star ac
je trouve qu'elle a une sublime voix oui
tu te serais vraiment retourné dit la
vérité
oui je refuserais la peau d'animaux la
toya jackson oui je sais la personne sur
soit en la personne que tu te serais
amené à samaa est-ce que tu serais allé
dans l'équipe de jennifer est bien sûr
c'est mon idéal passé la seule serait
retourné le faisons c'est jennifer si
vous plaît je trouve que tu peux gagner
avec ça va je trouve qu allen signature
vocale donc moi j'aime bien les idées
une signature de kahlaoui atur vocal on
connait que sa signature sur les
bulletins
attention jennifer se retourne à nouveau
on a un deuxième chanteur hockey
deuxième chanteur et après on en aura
[Rires]
je compte les jours jusqu'à ton retour
les années sont passées mais comme je
t'aime on dirait que ça fait que
quelques jours si tu étais là le temps
n'existerait pas on m'a dit du mal sur
toi je n'y crois pas je ne veux pas que
l'on recevait par de toi j'écoute
lavours ta voix tant les échos de ce
qu'on me dit sur toi ils rendent la
route sinueuse un labyrinthe mais moi je
te crois par l'intermédiaire de cette
chanson veux tu de moi c'est une demande
écrite je sais que je te mérite notre
amour est stabilisé impossible
déstabiliser jamais tiraillée nos coeurs
jamais séparés c'est comme au premier
jour
quinze ans après le coup de foudre dure
toujours on tient le coup on se bat
c'est vrai sur les coups de tonnerre on
tire pas très bons parlant km en année
en heure tous mesure c'est pas du
prêt-à-porter ce que je te propose c'est
une robe sur mesure
j'ai les moyens de toutes les vitrines
que tu regardes que dieu nous garde
esther
je tends ma main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un honneur au pas extrêmement fun
il est fabuleux c'est beau ce qu'il a
fait et on reconnaît un bios manque des
deux est un très bon
alors attention parce que là encore
jennifer retourne toi les chéris on va
accueillir la troisième chanteuse la
troisième chanteuse aller où merci alors
je vais demander de ne pas parler pour
l'instant
la troisième chanteuse venait près de
moi c'est une énorme surprise pour
jennifer jennifer ne s'attend pas du
tout elle est là on va voir ça va se
retourner ou pas parce que c'est pas
forcément le métier de la personne on
avait une surprise pour jean alors on va
demander à la personne de descendre
jennifer sache-le ça peut être une
surprise drôle donc tu n'es pas obligé
de te retourner d'accord sur une
personne qui va chanter une chanson
évoque le chantait on a quoi belval son
museau avant de chanter à just called to
say i just called to say i love you bien
sûr de justin bieber d'accord c'est de
stevie wonder tu connais j'adore tu peux
nous la faire comme ça toi juste c'est
[Musique]
vieux
j'ai vu merci venez faire on va écouter
la personne qui va te chanter à jesse
cox et à la vue c'est parti on y va à
jasko tu sais à elodie à chase co tous
ces métiers
à just called to say i love you and it
from the bottom of my alors à corps
attend des retombées ne te retourne pas
jennifer que tu ne t'es pas retourné
jennifer tu n'étais pas retourné sur la
voie qu'est une belle voix mais toi tu
aimes les bois singulière j'ai
l'impression très jeune et très jolie
voix soit reconnu cette voie non je n'ai
pas reconnu cette fois tu ne sais pas du
tout qu'il s'agit
non jennifer la personne ne le connais
même la paix pardon je suis me le
connais même la peine non jennifer tu
penses à qui ses magazines cannes ce qui
vous est alloué inc m base élèves est
oui non
[Applaudissements]
allah
c
sa mère si vanessa delà des crises allez
vous asseoir à les voilà partis jennifer
je sais
alors oui